[Music]
it was dark when two mysterious shrouded
figures appeared in the hillside village
the strangers knocked on every door in
town
asking for food and shelter
but again and again
they were turned away
soon
there was just one door left
that of a small
thatched shack
an elderly couple
horses and philemon
answered the thunderous knock
although there was something off about
these visitors
it was in the pair's nature to care for
those in need
philemon invited them to rest and the
cottage flooded with warmth as borsus
teased the fire back to life
when they were young
borsus and philemon had fallen in love
married and settled in the humble
cottage
decades later their home was still
standing and they were more devoted to
each other than ever
the strangers watched intently as bosses
nestled twigs under a battered pot
filled with vegetables
the couple could rarely afford meat but
in honor of their guests philemon cut
strips from an ageing shank for the stew
they made cheerful conversation and
offered their visitors hot baths
borsus used a chip of broken clay to
balance the wobbly table's legs and
rubbed its surface with mint until it
smelled sweet and fresh
weaving around each other with care the
couple transformed what they had into a
feast
soon the tabletop overflowed with food
and the last of their sweet wine
privately
borces and philemon
worried that their provisions would run
out
yet as the night wore on and their
strange guests took hearty gulps of wine
the clay vessel
never ran dry
the couple
at first relieved
grew terrified
their guests
weren't humble peasants traveling the
countryside
they were almost certainly
gods in disguise
but which gods
they didn't know
panicked that their preparations were
inadequate
borsus and philemon search for another
offering
the only precious thing left was the
goose that guarded their home
the couple repeatedly lunged after the
bird
but they were too worn out for the chase
so they prepared to receive the wrath of
the gods
their guests rose up
shedding their rags and mortal masks
looming before them was zeus the
storm-brewing ruler of the gods
and his son
hermes the fleet-footed messenger who
shepherded mortals to the underworld
the gods told the old couple that unlike
the other townspeople
they had shown
true xenia or loving hospitality to
strangers
they alone had passed the test
the gods commanded the couple to follow
them
and the group ascended the nearest
mountain
the summit borsis and philemon looked
back
but were shocked to see a murky swamp
where their village stood just moments
before
as punishment for refusing to shelter
the gods zeus and hermes had cast the
townspeople under water
leaving only their hosts home intact
recalling their friends and neighbors
borsus and philemon couldn't hide their
terror and mournful tears
even as their house transformed below
it grew larger and sprouted marble
pillars and steps legends edged
themselves onto its grand doors
their rickety cottage had metamorphosed
into a gleaming temple for the gods
hermes commended the couple and gently
asked if there was anything they desired
after a brief discussion
philemon requested that he and bosses be
permitted to care for the new temple and
he asked if when their time came
they could die together so neither would
have to face life without the other
tending to the temple and one another
they lived many more years
[Music]
until one day
horses noticed leaves fluttering from
her husband's hands
and looked down to find her own skin
hardening
they embraced
becoming rooted in place
vines wound
and canopies flourished overhead
they bid each other a loving last
farewell as humans
and where borsus and philemon had just
stood
bent with age
their towered a linden and an oak tree
their branches intertwined
for eternity
[Music]
zeus has a long history of dispensing
brutal punishments so what did
prometheus do to deserve a vulture
tearing out his liver day after day and
why was sisyphus sentenced to roll a
giant boulder up a hill again and again
dig into these myths of eternal doom to
find out